vino desde méxico por un año francia y
ya lleva 14 el 18 de enero pasado cuando
oxté el restaurante que fundó junto a su
esposa monserrat también chef y mexicana
amplia tres años se enteraron de que
habían ganado su primera estrella
michelín la mayor distinción de la
cocina francesa
como decimos sigo según las nubes aún
cuando empezamos a buscar el restaurante
mucha gente me decía gente que no es el
buen lugar
enrique nuestro el momento enrique
porque hacer la comida mexicana aquí
decimos que es una cocina donde se mete
en alto lo que aprendimos en francia sin
olvidar de dónde venimos de la cocina
que servimos en lo que es una cocina de
recuerdos con conservar mi esposa
entonces realmente son
son platillos que decíamos mono te
acuerdas cuando comíamos esto cuando
estábamos en la escuela o te acuerdas
cuando eras niño que ibas con tus papás
y comienza el producto
la distinción llega en momentos en que
usted al igual que todos los
restaurantes franceses que están
cerrados debido a la pandemia llegó
enrique y montse adaptaron el menú
gastronómico y los tradicionales 15
platos de su carta a una fórmula más
simple de dos platos para llevar hasta
con instrucciones de recalentado
tratamos de hacer una comida en la cual
tenga el toco de auster cuando tienes el
restaurante naturales para comer bien
está el restaurante pues para pasar un
buen momento una experiencia sobre todo
que aquí trabajamos con muchos productos
sabes que la gente no conoce y no es lo
mismo cuando lo tienes y tú le explicas
que cuando se le envíen un en un
papelito y te digo las explicaciones muy
bien radio nada no las tuvo un día
la fórmula está dando resultados y más
después de la estrella michelín aunque
enrique sigue con los pies en la tierra
lo siguiente tiene suerte puede que sea
él mismo quien le lleve el plato a su
casa